We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
Here's a voicemail about non voters.
Hi, David.
On sixty two and a lifelong voter, I was join
you.
What can I tell friends who have no interest
in voting?
What do I tell them?
How do I convince others that they need to
vote?
This is a whole topic, but my strategy that
I anecdotally believe is the most effective
is to explain to people if you're up.
Out because you don't think your vote makes
a difference, you're actually helping someone
by not voting.
Not voting is an active decision and you're
still making the decision by not voting.
It just may not be the decision you want to
be making when you opt out.
You are not saying I am.
You might be thinking that you're saying I
dislike every candidate, so I'm not participating.
But you are still helping one candidate over
another when you choose not to vote.
And most importantly, about not voters.
If everybody who had this thought, my vote
doesn't matter.
So I'm going to stay home.
If all of those people didn't stay home as
a group, their votes would now very much matter
and would be powerful enough to flip elections.
That's what I've found most effective to talk
to nonvoters.
But most importantly, make sure that they
know you're still choosing when you don't
vote and you might be choosing for the person
you.
You like the least to be actually the one
elected.
I've made some progress with that argument
with with small groups of people.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Don't miss it.
David Pakman dot com slash membership.
Get a membership and get instant access.
We'll see you then.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman dot
com.